all right everyone we have a pretty
important question to answer today and
it was made at a congressional hearing
recently I think uh November
20th by one Jasmine Crockett Democrat of
Texas
congresswoman a young African-American
congresswoman and she made a very uh
important question or she asked several
questions uh but first some
background of what this was about the
hearing had to do with Dei
diversity equity and
inclusion and uh Jasmine Crockett was
arguing on behalf of Dei practices and
why they're so important and at one
point uh very passionately she declared
and here are the questions and I quote
you tell me which white man was dragged
out of their homes you tell me which one
of them got dragged all the way across
an ocean and told that you're going to
go to work we're going to steal your
wives we're going to rape your wives
that didn't happen Happ that is
oppression so those are her questions so
obviously there's an assumption behind
her questions the white man to use her
words has never experienced what the
black man has he's never been dragged
out of his house he's never been forced
to do work labor and his women folk have
not been uh
raped okay and uh there's a logic to
that her what she's ultimately saying is
that you white people haven't
experienced this you don't know a
oppression and oppression is such that
the only way to get over it is through
things like Dei Because unless you've
experienced it you don't know how
traumatizing it is of course slavery
didn't happen to any black person living
in America today of course and no white
person enslaved them these are the
ancestors the ancestors of today's
African-Americans and the ancestors of
or some of the ancestors of both groups
whites and blacks uh were involved in
this but at any rate according to her
because uh White have not experienced
this they don't know how traumatic it
was and therefore they don't understand
why Dei is important all right so as to
her questions I think we should give her
an answer you tell me which white man
was dragged out of their homes and
dragged all the way across an ocean told
they're going to go to work and we're
going to steal your wives etc
etc all right so before we begin and
needless to say I think it's important
to clarify something slavery is not just
a white man on black man thing
unfortunately that's how it's apparently
taught or understood today slavery is
just something that happened when white
men enslaved blacks from Africa and
brought them to the United States the
transatlantic slave trade etc etc yeah
that did happen and I believe that was
very bad but it's not the definition of
slavery throughout history I think every
single race and ethnicity if you want to
use that word has at one time or another
been enslaved whites have enslaved
whites Whit have enslaved blacks blacks
have enslaved blacks blacks have
enslaved whites and every shade and
color in between has enslaved each other
and others that's just history um
probably to Miss Jasmine Crockett it
doesn't matter that whites enslaved
whites because probably in her mind um
what's makes slavery so bad is when One
race enslaves another so to that end
I'll give a few statistics concerning
non-white slavery of whites which I I
think apparently a lot of people such as
Miss Crockett are completely unaware of
so um let's start with the barbery
enslavement so the Muslims of North
Africa and we have records of this and
it's well documented between the 16th
and 18th century or even the 19th
century really and to give you the exact
dates uh I'm quoting from a professor
Robert Davis he's a professor I believe
emirus at Ohio State a historian
and um I'm quoting him he writes between
1530 and 1780 there were almost
certainly a million and quite possibly
as many as a million and a quarter white
European Christians enslaved by the
Muslims of the barbery
coast and I believe that's from his book
with the title white slaves Black
Masters or Black Masters white slaves
and there's a lot more statistics in
there all right that's just one uh
during the Tatar Yoke the tatars are the
Mongols who were islamized and became
Muslims and um
enslaved again to give you a rough
estimate between 1450 and
1780 um approximately 3 million slaves
Eastern Europeans uh poles Russians
ukrainians lithuanians were enslaved and
so sold on the Crimean slave market okay
so uh you know to answer her question
you tell me which white man was dragged
out of their homes just based on those
two examples we're talking about 4.25
million whites who were enslaved by
non-whites now this is just really the
tip of the iceberg I can give you more
stats and numbers and we have numbers
from specific years so for example in
1438 bartolomew diano an Italian
Franciscan who was held up in
Constantinople during one of its many
sieges it still had not been conquered
it's 14 38 he described all the slaves
that were being uh ins or the Europeans
and the Christians were being enslaved
by the Turks during this time so in 1438
that year alone he talked about
300,000 Christians were enslaved and
carried off in just a few days that's
his quote from Hungary and from Serbia
and Transylvania that same year 100,000
were LED away in Iron feds tied to the
backs of horses women and children were
hurted by dogs without any Mercy or
piety if one of them slowed down unable
to walk further because of thirst or
pain oh good Jesus she IM immediately
ended her life there in torment cut in
half so that's just a little description
along with the numbers and the
statistics and uh again you know a lot
of these numbers come from the modern
era which uh traditionally historians
date to 1500 and after 1500 but if you
look at the sources both Muslim and
Christian and and in between you'll read
about Europeans and Christians being
enslaved and you may not get a number
but you'll the the Chronicles will write
a vast amount of Christians were
enslaved and hauled off and taken to
North Africa or the Middle East etc etc
that's habitual and that goes on all
throughout in the be uh not sorry not
the BC times if we're talking about
Islam um you know at the Battle of Tours
in 732 right before that we get records
of constant enslavement of Europeans in
Spain of course and into France and all
throughout the mediter Anan so there's
copious records wherever you look as
late as I believe the 16th century you
have records of Muslims from Barber
going as far as Iceland okay that's
pretty far to get Christian white slaves
and bring them back to Africa where they
were
sold as far as our other question you
know uh you tell me which white man was
told we're going to steal your wives
we're going to rape your wives that also
happened uh a lot
and uh we know that because if you look
along with all the the slaves of course
women were there but you also find
records it goes all the way back to
Muhammad where when he was uh before the
tabuk Campa campaign he was trying to
rile up his men his followers to go and
fight and attack the Eastern Roman
Empire the
byzantines and uh he says do you not
want the women of the benu alar benar
literally means a people of yellow and
uh historians and linguists have tried
to understand what that means most think
it means light-haired people fair or
fair skinned the pale people uh but it's
there and
also just throughout this if you look at
my books I have a lot of quotations uh
sword and simitar Defenders of the West
you'll read about Muslims and Mongols
and so forth and how they coveted
European women for their harams and uh
as
slaves so to answer her question yes
white women were raped by non-whites as
slaves and conquer
bines so in short and to answer her
questions yes white people have been
enslaved including by non-whites many
millions uh throughout history now the
problem with the fake history that she's
operating under and which is so
widespread and entrenched the idea that
the only people who ever enslaved anyone
are white people and they enslaved black
people uh the the problem with that well
there's many problems but one of them
which we can look at right now the
dangers of fake history which I like to
talk about is the white people who were
enslaved by the various peoples the
Mongols and the Muslims and the berbers
etc etc never got
reparations they were never given Dei or
affirmative action and they managed to
Rise Above It other people too not just
whites other people who have been
enslaved non-whites who were enslaved by
non-whites or whites were able and uh to
rise above it through sheer will
determination hard work perseverance
that's the way of the world it's not
about freebies that's not what helps you
develop these good traits to have
perseverance but if you think the only
way that you can achieve some sort of
equality is always by freebies and
handouts which essentially is what Dei
is then you will never cultivate these
virtues perseverance and hard work and
Rising above uh the negative things I I
I want to say you but no your ancestors
have been through uh slavery which again
all of us trust me
our ancestors somewhere down the line
have been enslaved certainly by our
understanding of the word enslavement so
if you think the only way to rise above
it is to get freebies that will always
keep you in a way a Perpetual slave
who's never able to break the mold and
rise above it all all right so there's
the answer to M Crockett's burning
questions bye